hello jc i'm david and i'm andrea and
this is the very very crazy story of how
we turned our apartment into
a popular bakery in the middle of a
pandemic
we moved to mexico city because i had a
residency and artistic residency here i
organized exhibitions i'm a curator and
i also write i had a residency in
switzerland and david has some projects
in portland and all of the studying the
pandemic strikes and we don't really
know what to do we were just like in awe
sitting at home missing the
gigs but also the money that we needed
to leave it went away with those gigs
being cancelled
we had like this pinterest board that
was called foreign baking container is
spanglish thing it's like quarantine
baking thing is we don't even have an
oven because our apartment doesn't have
an oven we just like went online and
paid by car that very small hamilton
beach oven a toaster oven for yeah
we decided to just give it a shot and a
few recipes that we wanted to do and
then exchange with friends because we're
just like trying out recipes so we're
just begin sending it to friends and
like posted it online and some people
start to notice it and they ask us if we
sell it and we're like no we're not
doing this for money and then it starts
happening more and more and we're like
are we selling it becomes a hit and we
don't know when that started to happen
like all of the sudden we had a menu
that we came up like from the top of our
heads everybody asked like how did it
start what did you do to become so
famous and
we have no idea yeah
[Music]
so this is our workspace which is
originally a
bedroom but that's what we have
basically the whole apartment is one
very big kitchen we've kind of adapted
some of the boxes so that they are
ourselves for more ingredients a typical
week for us starts on tuesday when we
begin prepping up for
the our brownie special that we do on
wednesdays
and for brownies we do salted caramel
and
nutella brownies we start by browning
the butter and this is really important
because it gives them
a sort of caramelized flavor melting the
chocolate we usually mix two different
kinds of chocolate that we put with the
butter after it's melted we put it on a
mixer with the sugars we also use brown
sugar and white sugar
and then we add the eggs we mix it up
very very well and then we add salt and
vanilla and then we finish off with our
flour but also with a cocoa powder we
put it on a tray and then from there
they can become either caramel or
nutella brownie we did a lot of prepping
today but we're nowhere near ready
there's a lot of baking that needs to
happen tomorrow people are going to be
arriving quite soon in the afternoon so
we have to get up quite early and bust
ourselves off instagram is exploding a
little bit so we need to organize orders
for tomorrow we are here to put a order
system in place we do everything
manually which is a nightmare so it's 10
30.
we're very tired we're already in bed
and we're ordering some supplies for
tomorrow
like
a ton of
maxi chocolate we're also in a pandemic
so
we are afraid to go to
central markets to get the product it
was supposed to be a quiet day but it
was a bit crazy there's no such thing as
a quiet day
[Music]
it is 6 30 a.m
[Music]
we're trying to get up we had to wake up
very early today because we need to
start baking
[Music]
it's a bit messy
but you know remember it's a home
project this is our setup for brownies
and blondies for the morning except for
the ones that we baked yesterday so for
the doomsayer blondies we start by
browning the butter because it gives
them caramelized flavor and then we mix
that with the sugars we use both white
and brown sugars then we mix that really
well until it forms this sort of paste
and the sugar kind of melts a little bit
and then we add in the vanilla and the
eggs then when that's very well
incorporated we add in our flours
salt
and that is it it's a it's a very basic
recipe but it is it's just all about the
baking times and the mixings we add
around 160 grams of tulsa chipper batch
okay so off we go
we have to bake for like 10 hours
straight so that we can make our blondie
badges for the day a number of friends
come over to help us they're all artists
who are jobless like us so two of them
paola and jorelli usually come
wednesdays and they help us out with the
frenzy of cooking baking and at the same
time taking orders delivering okay so
the brownies and blondies are not done
yet and we have not packed a single box
but we have an interview with telemundo
right now so that makes our day a lot
more complicated it is amazing that so
many people are interested in what
you're doing so this is for our pop-up
on saturday so we're working with a
place called cadencia they sell flowers
and plants it's a really beautiful shop
so i think we're done with the flyer now
and we'll get battle cakes so it's
almost 2 p.m and things will
get out of control real fast because
there will be a number of people looking
for their
sugar we have started packing but we
will probably keep on packing when the
clients are coming and now everybody is
starting to arrive we are running around
trying to deliver to hand in our orders
[Music]
and sometimes you go downstairs to
hunting something and there's already
more people there and we have to run
upstairs finish painting
take something out of the oven hola
and then run downstairs with new orders
pretty much every time yeah we also have
to organize tomorrow and making
everything for the pop-up so tomorrow
and friday are very crazy days and today
is our chance to organize that so this
is it for putting today
so it's thursday morning it gets
progressively difficult to get up in the
morning
i am very behind on social media we get
tons of messages and yesterday was a bit
crazy so we have orders we have messages
of people like asking questions they
want to know which flavors we have they
want to know our menu they want to know
where the pop-up will be so i am very
behind we also get very nice comments
like people just writing to say hey what
you're doing is amazing we love you
thank you
and those are great
[Applause]
[Music]
this is like a seven ingredient recipe
david is coming in with some tartar
queso and we're also making a carrot
today we are doing a carrot cake and
this is just lotus cookie and butter
which has a lot of scrum on top and it's
really nice because it blends well so
we're making this sort of caramel
brookie and now we are rolling the
churro cookie and cinnamon sugar
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay we are done with the cakes for
today
good morning
we're declining as we go and we still
have the worst day ahead of us like 14
15 hours of baking this is the farthest
pop-up we've ever done we have never
gone that far we are usually at
locations very close to where we're
working at so i'm very nervous to see
how it
it works out to see how many people show
up if someone shows up we don't really
know how many people
know about us there i don't know if it's
going to be 10 people or 200 you know
and we could also get you know like rain
and then nobody wants to come and then
we screwed we are making the carrot
spice
[Music]
and this is our tres leches
berries cake jar so the apartment looks
like this right now this is our living
room
david in the kitchen and everything is a
bit of a mess we have some boxes there
i'm sorry
12 30 at night our kitchen is a huge
mess
[Music]
it's almost 1 a.m
and we will try to sleep for
about 4 hours
and then we will try to crawl out of bed
for half an hour and then we will begin
baking again
for the pop-up it's a thing that we
really like because it's a moment that
we have contact with people we actually
see human beings and this is the only
opportunity that we have to actually you
know like interact with people and it's
our major selling day also we're going
to take our table and acrylic between
that we made for this we're 20 minutes
away from opening and we're finishing
setting up and everything looks great
sunny finally coming out high hopes for
a good sale today
[Music]
we usually try to do more products that
we don't have when we do our mid-week
specials cake jars which are a major
thing because people love textures we
also do special cookies you can have
brownies by the piece which you cannot
buy from us during the week and then we
do a burnt cheesecake and we top it off
of course with good leche and cookies
and people are crazy about it it's
really good
we don't know what's going to happen we
don't know exactly what we want to do we
know that we want to keep on going yes
we don't want like a huge project we
don't want to be everywhere we want to
keep it simple we want to keep it close
to people we want to continue like this
sort of homemade thing we like the
pop-ups we like to kind of travel and
reach a lot of places so we're thinking
about for example pop-ups
in all of mexico and not only mexico
city so you know like monterrey
yeah i never knew that i could work this
hard for so long and for so many days in
a row it has really put us to the test
yeah it's definitely a challenge it's a
challenge because it's not only you have
to be in your home 24 7 because of the
pandemic but you're also having to work
with your couple but we have pulled
through so
it's a very nice thing to discover we
don't know how to express how grateful
we are how happy we are with this thank
you for watching thank you so so much
for all of your support for just being
there and we'll see you soon
oh yes
[Music]
you